see
you steve very nice to see you i was at
the screening the other day and saw you
guys but i was wearing a mask and you
know
that wasn't coming off um let me start
by saying congrats you once again made
me look away from the screen
i think a few times um so i'm just going
to say well done
um thank you i want to jump backwards
actually when you guys were making the
first
film what was your optimistic goal for
how well the film might do
our optimistic goal is that it didn't
crash and burn yeah yeah
they were not going to kick us out of
the country back to uruguay they would
take our green cards away
we might this time but the first time
around that was
because look we had we were lucky that
evil dead
our first film was so successful it was
number one movie when it opened
and opened big so there was something we
knew for a fact
that uh our own literal original movie
with healthy budget
we you know we know iep or what
of no kind was ever gonna top that one
that that's the only thing we knew for a
fact
and then it opened even bigger and i've
been a huge success so
who never saw that coming and you were
with us the night uh if i even remember
correctly in austin
i think with uh we don't breed you host
q a at some point for us
comic-con a comic-con exactly yeah
that's a whole nother story i'll never
forget that night actually
that's a whole man i could talk about
that so i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of movies
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of the first
film
and what would surprise people about
making the sequel
the first one i mean i'm always
surprising about that
but i wasn't even going to direct it i
think that's that's the
i don't know if everyone knows that um i
i
we wrote it and we thought like i'm
gonna direct this
so we should find a director who wants
to do it and then no one's gonna do it
we literally offered to people that said
like no thank you and
and they were um probably running out of
money
and we thought like well you know you
told me earlier rob tapper is thinking
sam raimi's fire is like very you young
you need to make a movie you're stuck
with this one
and i was like okay let's go let's kill
our careers
and uh and we went and we made it that's
something people i don't know a lot of
people know
um i wish i could say yeah we had a
vision
we knew was gonna be a success we did
not and
and then and this time around i managed
to go like no
this time i did the way now i watched
the movie i'm like
damn it should have made it myself you
know what surprised me
uh in this movie is uh stephen lang
he's the nicest sweetest man ever he's
such a charming man
and we would be having breakfast before
shooting and he's just
himself and then on set
with all his makeup and everything on he
becomes
norman 100 so i would just approach him
hey slang you know and he's like
i was looking at all the times like that
i'm like oh okay okay
okay okay you do whatever you want man
you got it he's like
he's got that presence on set at all
times at all times he's
amazing and then at night he goes back
to the hotel and he's again the sweetest
guy is such a transformation
he turns into the character when he
walks on set is him i told you it was
one of my few advices going in i was
like remember that you cannot
you know you're going to pretend slang
slang is stephen langford that's how you
call him if you know him
it's like you're going to pretend slang
to go into the scene like
pump him up do all these terrible things
and then suddenly be the nicest guy at
the same time there's no way he's either
or once you
empty you you're prime him for that like
he stays in character it is that's
really
scary and brilliant to see on set it's
interesting how each actor likes to work
and how some
will be the loosest they could be and
then to flip it on
the second you know um but i wanted to
talk to you guys you guys put some
pretty messed up stuff on film
have you had any battles with the mpaa
over any shots
or have they been pretty lenient with
you well i think well not really
evil dead maybe had it yeah yeah this
one had a bit of a
now usually we're like five frames away
from nc 17
that's what happened every time with us
it's like it's not a new concept
it's the same concept you see in the
movie only that
probably on the first cut they were
exposed a bit more
so overexposed so we we had to pull back
a little bit and sometimes
make i think every time we had made for
a better cut
we you know we evil dead had a lot of
that
those moments you would just show a
little bit more i i i don't know i mean
i don't know
the the logic of the mpa is like if you
see five more frames you're [ __ ] up
forever
if you don't you'll be okay i don't know
but that seems to be the logic
yeah they're full of [ __ ] but you can't
say that um i i can though
it is censorship uh you know which you
know it's messed up man um
i love learning about the editing
process because that's where it all
comes together
can you guys talk about what what you
went through in the editing room for
don't breathe to
did you ever have a much longer version
did you have any big changes that
happened as a result of the editing
process
you know what no not really i think
uh what you guys are gonna see is the
director's cut
there's there's uh they the everybody
producers in the studio gave us a lot of
freedom to do whatever we felt was
better for the for the movie
and uh our editor jan kovat
such a talented man and and a pleasure
to work with
helped so much you know editors make you
revisit the story and they bring a new
perspective and they
have ideas on how to maybe piece the
whole thing together in a different way
and maybe
and they surprised you and you're like
oh oh my god that's even better than
than what we envisioned and also fede
came in
and and have some ideas on how to
reshape some scenes
but uh the cut you're gonna see is the
cut that we love
and there's there's there's uh nothing
that we left out
this is something that happened with
some movies and you just have to see
them to to believe me
it's like we write them in a way and the
first movie is a good example
this is the same that we write them in a
way that you can not [ __ ] up with them
there's no way you can lift the scene
out of it
it's just the thing collapses it would
make no sense
it's such a from here to there from
there to there so if you suddenly cut it
and he's from here
up there you gotta go wait a second how
did he made it there's no way and so the
story
we try to really craft them in the way
but then there's not a lot you can do
we can reshape or really work in the way
we cut a scene
but the structure is it's such a
solid thing on the script usually that
there's just no way you can tamper with
it i mean
look at donbrewana imagine if there's a
moment you go like i would have cut out
that out it's
unlikely every piece has a moment the
same with this one it's just every piece
has its purpose in a way that it was
crafted like that on the script it makes
it very difficult
to lift them out right so that's why um
from evil dead to the evil dead had a
little bit more like stuff that we left
out and that's why
you know there's a there's an extended
cut but uh the don't breed movies at
least there's such a
machine of plot that it's really hard to
get to stick stuff out right i have to
stop there i'm just going to say
congrats guys i look forward to whatever
you guys are going to do next
thank you for giving me your time thank
you thank you